[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ho mai pensato veramente che fare
l'illustratore fosse un lavoro possibile
sinceramente pensavo che per pagare le
bollette pagare l'affitto per chiunque
avesse diciamo un attitudine al disegno
o all'illustrazione alla fine sarebbe
stato meglio fare un qualcosa di più
diciamo concreto come lavorare come
grafico come pubblicitario ecco perché
all'inizio della mia carriera ho
lavorato come art director in pubblicità
poi un'altra convinzione che aveva era
quella che non mezzo vuoto
alla fine sarei finito a vivere ea
lavorare a new york la città dei miei
sogni
ecco che per coronare diciamo più la
seconda parte decidono il 2012 con la
mia ragazza di partire per new york per
la nostra prima volta lì la classica
vacanza dieci giorni in relax
poi io in maniera astuta avrei piazzato
qualche colloquio qualche incontro per
capire il mercato insomma se come art
director fossi stato a livello del del
livello medio americano quindi nel 2012
ottobre 2012 atterriamo già qualcosa non
torna il pilota appena arrivati si scusa
di un qualcosa dice una certa sandy ce
ne freghiamo
ho capito andiamo in città andiamo a
manhattan e passeggiamo felici però ci
accorgiamo che fuori dai negozi sono dei
cartelli con scritto per colpa di sandy
chiuderemo alle 3 per colpa di sandy i
mezzi pubblici smetteranno di funzionare
tra e mezza
non capiamo cominciamo a chiedere in
giro e scopriamo che sarebbe successo
questo
new york da lì a qualche ora sarebbe
stata diciamo invasa da una tempesta
uragano che spegne ha spento metà new
york da times square in giù bloccando la
città mezzi pubblici non funzionavano
traffico incredibile perché ovviamente
tutti si mettevano in macchina noi dei
nostri dieci giorni 5 6 li abbiamo
passati chiusi in albergo dove ci
avvertivano di non uscire per non
rischiare la vita
i restanti quattro giorni a passeggiare
per una città fondamentalmente inutile e
ovviamente anche i miei colloqui perché
uffici chiusi nessuna possibilità di
fare proprio neanche una mezza
chiacchiera quindi rientriamo in italia
questa cosa mi brucia un po continua a
crescere e crescere nel 2013 quindi
neanche tempo sei mesi
decido che ci devo provare con più
convinzione
però devo andarci convinto domandarci
preparato quindi decido che devo
contattare tutti i grandi a director
delle agenzie pubblicitarie e nel caso
non mi avessero risposto mi sarei
presentato di persona incontra sorpresa
eccomi qua
guardami ci sono però non voglio nessun
paracadute non voglio alibi non voglio
motivi per mollare quindi do le
dimissioni non ho un lavoro sono
disoccupato parto per new york per
attirare l'attenzione dei direttori
creativi disegno la mia storia la mia
storia illustrata senza strada a
scrivere la mail e ciao scusa mi sono no
ti racconto la mia storia come un libro
per bambini persone
i clienti mostruosi terribili che mi
chiedevano le cose più indicibili
parlo del mio viaggio a new york che
sono lì apposta per loro la mail si
chiude con un sì o un no il direttore
creativo poteva cliccare sì mi arrivava
una mail precompilata non doveva
sbattersi scriveva l'orario scriveva al
giorno e mi diceva mi fissava
l'appuntamento cliccavano non doveva
sbattersi a scrivermi mi dispiace mi
arrivava gia la meta viene mi dispiace
non abbiamo voluto incontrarti
grazie a questa storia i risultati sono
stati veramente straordinari ho ricevuto
il 100 per cento di risultati negativi
allora bisogna un attimo spiegarle però
il 70 per cento effettivamente non ha
risposto il 20 per cento ha appunto
cliccato no il 10 per cento mi ha
confermato il colloquio quindi c'è stato
anche un motivo di gaudì inizialmente
però poi una volta presentati già si
capiva che non sponsorship nessuna
possibilità per i proprio zero
ovviamente la frustrazione aumenta
perché chi incontro tutti che hanno in
una maniera o nell'altra realizzato il
proprio sogno americano e quindi
comincio diverse new york ce la puoi
fare a tutti alla fine ottengono una
possibilità qui quindi mi gioco la carta
dell'incontro a sorpresa mi presento le
agenzie e dico ragazzi io sono qua sono
vito posta per l'italia per voi vogliono
incontro col direttore creativo
mi dicono che senza un incontro
preparato fissato io non posso stare li
dimentico che dopo l'undici settembre le
cose le policy di sicurezza sono un
attimo diciamo cresciute quindi io
insisto dico che voglio rimanere lì che
voglio il mio colloquio e loro mi fanno
scortare da una guardia fuori le cose
non vanno tanto bene quindi rientro in
italia
allora dico proviamo con londra proprio
con londra stesso mines conosco gente e
vedo vedo direttori creativi qui va un
po meglio
arrivò addirittura in finale con un
altro art director inglese per il posto
di ar diretto in una importante agenzia
pubblicitaria
il direttore creativo però se ne lava le
mani e dice io non voglio scegliere
siete entrambi a pari livello
quindi far scegliere i copy al
copywriter il tuo futuro compagno di
squadra diciamo tra me e il ragazzo
inglese che pensate abbia scelto non ha
scelto me cosa mi rispondo già così
quindi torno in italia sono disoccupato
mi conoscono più o meno come art
director e quindi comincio a valutare
l'idea che la mia passione da
illustratore forse ed a cominciare
proviamoci
vediamo come quindi mi apro due siti uno
da art director e uno da illustratore
oltretutto da illustratore per fare i
passi giusti contatto alcuni
illustratori italiani chiedendo dei
pareri sul mio stile come lavoro se
potrebbe funzionare come carriera
c'è chi mi motiva mi da dei giusti
consigli che invece mi dice senti come
totti stava andando bene in italia
continua a parlar director sa stare sta
cosa illustratore non è una carriera che
fa per te io mi intestardisco e mi apro
questi due siti pensando di raddoppiare
le possibilità di clienti e invece in
realtà mi arrivano delle mail che dicono
ascolta guarda che c'è uno che ai tuoi
stessi lavori però c'è un altro nome
perché no quale c'è un altro ma chi è
quello che ha fatto i lavori mi piace
l'illustratore che è di la meno conta
sto facendo confusione quindi chiudo il
sito dar director provo a mettermi il
cappello da illustrato dico raga io sono
un illustratore non è andata bene a new
york le ultime due volte nel 2015 la
frustrazione aumenta dico senti sai che
c'è io ci torno new york mi deve la mia
possibilità io voglio il sogno americano
e mi deve la mia
possibilità riparto da illustratore ma
il set
ancora diverso la città la conosco
alloggi a girata non mi interessa
so che andrò lì e conta però tutti i
giornali le riviste le agenzie di
pubblicità tutti i giorni non mi
interessa
non voglio andare in giro per la città
appena a terra contatto un'amica questa
mi offre ospitalità nel suo ufficio lei
fa la gente di fotografia indici c'è
tutto lo spazio per poterti mettere a
cercare circondando mail per i
successivi sette giorni mando mail otto
ore al giorno e ricevo totale tipo zero
risposte o al massimo le risposte che
ricevo solo risposte automatiche ciao
sono fuori per lavoro
non posso rispondere per un certo punto
succede una cosa mi arriva una mail una
inaspettata mi contatta il washington
post con una proposta vogliamo metterti
in copertina con una tua illustrazione
su un tema di temi e washington capitals
la nostra squadra di hockey andrà molto
probabilmente in finale e noi vogliamo
celebrare l'approdo finale diciamo che
arriveremo alle finali con una tua
illustrazione ok va bene
facciamola subito c'è un però come
centro è sì e stasera giochiamo la gara
decisiva
se vinciamo e andiamo in finale
illustrazione tua sparata gigante sul
magazine
se non vinciamo niente ha poi
avvantaggiarti se vuoi con così e i
tempi di consegna saranno più veloci
però sapere se perdiamo non ti verrà
rimborsato nulla deciso cosa fare poi
aspettare anche della fine dell'esito
della partita ragazzi il cantato al
washington post non comincio e inizio
mando degli schizzi loro mi approvano la
prima quella centrale sopra un giocatore
simbolo dei washington capitals sotto un
giocatore di tampa bay che sarebbe la
squadra che avrebbero incontrato in
finale cominciò la realizzò la mando
un'amica mi dice senti ma vuoi venire a
vedere la partita perché guarda caso
giocano contro new york andiamo a vedere
la partita però questa mia amica mi
porta a vederla nel covo dei rangers per
spiegarvi la meglio e come se io da
milanista andasse a vedere il derby
milan inter nel covo di interisti
sfegatati ne sto zitto una partita mi
abbia retta dopo tre minuti
washington segno
uno a zero siamo a cavallo ormai è fatta
sta facendo che la partita
secondo tempo new york pareggio nazione
fortuita veramente lasciam perdere
washington fa la partita terzo tempo non
segna nessuno
si va ai supplementari ai supplementari
succede questo i blu sono new york
ecco questi sono 2.800 dollari che vanno
in fumo con un'azione difesa male
ringraziamo washington
ovviamente qui o il crollo più totale ok
la mia unica possibilità questo è un
segno dall'alto lo leggo come signor
all'altro davide lascia perdere
farei l'illustratore non è il tuo non è
il tuo hai avuto la tua possibilità ha
difeso male basta cambia poi l'art
director riusciva bene quindi ovviamente
arrivo in ufficio dove era ospite con un
muso lunghissimo mikami grande successo
e allora evito di rispondere con
parolacce le spiego abbiamo perso e mi
fa ma ascolta ma perché non prendi
l'illustrazione che hai fatto
la cambi con lo yacht vincente e
lamandini ai magazine di new york si
perora gaia ci ho provato un sacco di
volte cioè ancora c'era ancora per
essere deluso un'altra volta non ha
risposto nessuno fino adesso
probabilmente non è il mio dovrò fare
altro però poi alla fine mi passa questa
diciamo questa mini depressione e quindi
cambio di illustrazione e realizzo
questa cominciò a mandarla i vari
magazine di new york il new york times e
risponde mi dice davide complimenti per
il lavoro non ci serve non la vogliamo
grazie però se vuoi passa ci facciamo
due chiacchiere capiamo insomma come
lavori come ecco però non me lo dire due
volte prendo chi lo sa patiscono
dell'ufficio corro sotto il new york
times e mando una mail che casuale non
pensavo di mandarla ciao ragazzi
casualmente sono qui sotto
posso salire secondo me cosa mi ha
risposto no c'è ma risposto no vediamoci
domani erano una riunione quindi il
giorno dopo
facciamo la riunione però io non mi
illudo alla fine la delusione
questo è stata troppo recente e quindi
come non si sa come andrà
però sono contento ho ottenuto il mio
colloquio
a un certo punto però dopo tre giorni mi
arriva effettivamente una richiesta da
loro impazzisco mi dicono davide ai
cinque ore di tempo perché c'è una
breaking news hanno appena beccato
blatter con le mani nella marmellata
la terra era l'ex presidente fifa
l'hanno beccato che distribuiva mazzette
insieme a tutto l'establishment fifa
serve una illustrazione mi mandano
l'articolo
e io lì non capisco più niente fatti più
o meno i ricordi vanno in sequenza così
è più o meno alla stessa velocità mi
chiama new york times curlo mi dico
perché lui mi ha chiamato new york times
ok prendo chiamo un taxi sangue in taxi
per correre a casa a lavorare chiamo la
mia ragazza erano iap l'eredità del
oraria la favorevole dico mi ha chiamato
mio tex lei urla non urlare sono al
telefono
metto giù il telefono uscendo al taxi
bacall tax do la mancia troppo a mancia
non importa
sto andando se entro in casa accendo la
luce nel cielo non si spenga la luce si
brucia la lampadina ma non importa nella
gestione allora prendo mi metto davanti
al computer e comincia a man a lavorare
leggo l'articolo pensa mando le proposte
tutte incentrate su blatter mentre
aspetto che mi diano una risposta alle
mie diciamo quattro proposte il cambio
la lampadina arriva la risposta cannate
tutte la mia unica possibilità bruciata
con delle proposte a quanto pare non a
livello loro mi spiegano che erano tutte
troppo incentrate su blatter e che
invece era un cosa che doveva riguardare
tutta la fifa grazie ci hai provato il
tempo è troppo poco insomma va bene così
ci hai provato e facendo ragazzi no vi
prego datemi un'altra mezz'ora di tempo
ma con mezz'ora di tempo avessi tre ore
di tempo per realizzare illustrazioni
sei sicuro dammi mezz'ora di tempo e ti
dall illustrazione mi danno questa
mezz'ora di tempo comincia a pensare
allora fifa cosa fa la fila
la fifa organizza i mondiali finiti i
mondiali
manifestazione più importante quindi
hanno rotto la fifa no hanno rotto la
fita faccio una coppa del mondo rotta
col mondo rottanova il mondo è solida
coppa del mondo mondo mondo il mondo è
mondo è tondo con una lampadina
lampadina bruciata faccio che hanno
sgamato il mondo che hanno rovinato e
quindi facciamo che hanno cambiato il
mondo alla coppa del mondo
mando questo schizzo appunto due mani
che lo vedono me lo approvano subito vai
realizza l'illustrazione io in tre ore
di tempo
chiudo l'illustrazione che diventi è
così ovviamente la diretta dall altra
parte
felicissimo io so di che già mi sto
pregustando la mia entrata in edicola
tipo mi dia la copia del new york times
per leggere sotto il mio nomino sotto
arriva una mail
cosa c'è adesso l'editor la vista e ha
detto bellissima è però è perfetta per
quando cambieranno tutto il management
della fifa e ci saranno le effettive
dimissioni di blatter
ok ma è quindi questo quando succederà e
non tra un anno in anno quindi
effettivamente poi sono sincero è uscita
è uscito un anno dopo fatta in tre ore
per la mattina successiva però è uscita
un anno dopo
diciamo che questa illustrazione ha
rotto diciamo così degli argini e da lì
ho continuato a lavorare per loro
per altri brand sportivi del
dell'editoria per pubblicità per squadre
sportive anche qui sono alcune appunto
dei progetti ai quali ho lavorato
recentemente però in conclusione se sono
qui a parlarvi è perché sono un
illustratore adesso al 100 per cento ma
probabilmente anzi quasi sicuramente se
non mi fosse andata di sfiga per tutto
questo tempo
ora non sarei qui a parlarvi quindi in
attesa della mia prossima sfortuna
vi ringrazio di avermi ascoltato
[Applauso]